BRIAN:  LET’S BRING IN LARRY
KUDLOW NOW YOU KNOW LARRY HE’S
THE NATIONAL ECONOMIC COUNCIL
DIRECTOR HE’S WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LARRY SO
MUCH PRESSURE ON YOUR SHOW TO
TRY TO BRING THIS ECONOMY BACK
AFTER A SHUTDOWN, THE SELF-
INFLICTED SHUTDOWN OF
THE COUNTRY.
FIRST THINGS FIRST THE PRESIDENT
IS GOING TO MAKE SOME NEWS TODAY
ONE OF OUR TOP TRADING PARTNERS
CHINA WHAT THEY’RE DOING IN HONG
KONG, AND THE WAY THEY HAVE BEEN
ACTING WITH THIS VIRUS IS GOING
TO PROMPT SOME TYPE OF WHITE
HOUSE ACTION TODAY.
WHAT COULD YOU GIVE US AN IDEA
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
BE SIGNING?
>> LOOK, STEP BACK A SECOND.
CHINA HAS BEHAVED VERY BADLY,
LACK OF INFORMATION, LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, LACK OF
COOPERATION REGARDING THE VIRUS
AND IN WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, DID A LOT OF
DAMAGE.
WE KNOW THE ORIGIN WAS IN CHINA,
AND IF THEY HAD TOLD THE TRUTH
PERHAPS THINGS WOULD HAVE BEEN A
LOT EASIER FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD, WHERE TRAGICALLY,
TRAGICALLY, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
KILLED.
NOW WE’RE COMING TO THE END OF
THAT, WHICH IS THE GOOD NEWS IN
THE U.S..
REGARDING HONG KONG, BRIAN, THE
BREAKING NEWS THIS WEEK, OF
COURSE CHINA IS NOW VIOLATING A
50-YEAR-OLD TREATY SIGNED BY
MARGARET THATCHER IN THE LATE
1980S AND SHE WAS BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER.
THE IDEA WAS ONE COUNTRY TWO
SYSTEMS, AND HONG KONG WAS TO BE
A FREE MARKET ORIENTED
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM.
CHINA’S NOW VIOLATING THAT BY
TAKING OVER NATIONAL SECURITY,
PEOPLE OF HONG KONG ARE CURIOUS
AND WE WILL NOT SECRETARY OF
STATE POMPEO, NO AUTONOMY ANY
MORE FOR HONG KONG.
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE SOME
IDEAS TO HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE
AND FRANKLY, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
IS, I’LL USE THE WORD FURIOUS AT
WHAT CHINA HAS DONE IN RECENT
DAYS, WEEKS, AND MONTHS.
THEY HAVE NOT BEHAVED WELL AND
THEY HAVE LOST THE TRUST I THINK
OF THE WHOLE WESTERN WORLD.
STEVE: WELL THEY CERTAINLY HAVE
A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO DO.
LARRY, I UNDERSTAND LATER TODAY,
THERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE IS AN
ECONOMIC ROUND TABLE.
WHAT DO YOU HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH?
>> WE’LL BE TALKING WITH
LEADING CEO’S STEVE, COVERING
THE WATERFRONT.
THE THINGS ARE LOOKING BETTER,
NOW WE’RE STILL IN THE PANDEMIC
CONTRACTION, WE PROBABLY HAVEN’T
PEAKED IN UNEMPLOYMENT, AND THE
NUMBERS COMING IN IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD ARE GOING TO BE
VERY POOR HERE IN THE SECOND
QUARTER IT’S A LOT OF HARDSHIP,
A LOT OF HEARTBREAK, A LOT OF
ANXIETY, SO IT CERTAINLY ISN’T
OVER BUT, BUT, I WILL SAY THIS
THE VIRUS IS FLATTENING AND
COMING DOWNWARD, THE OPENINGS
ARE COMING ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
BUSINESSES ARE OPENING, NEW
BUSINESS APPLICATIONS ARE
OPENING, IT’S KIND OF A LIST,
STEVE OF I CALL THEM GLIMMERS OF
HOPE AND GROWTH.
CARS ARE DRIVING MORE, GASOLINE
PRICES ARE UP, THE MOBILITY
INDEX IS UP.
WE’RE EVEN SEEING ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS WHICH IS
A TERRIBLE NUMBER, CLOSE TO
40 MILLION BUT IT IS SLOWING IN
ITS INCREASE SO THERE’S HOPEFUL
SIGNS AND I THINK WE’RE GOING TO
MOVE STRONG INTO THE SECOND HALF
OF THE YEAR, WITH PERHAPS AS
MUCH AS 20% ECONOMIC GROWTH.
WE’LL TALK ABOUT THIS WITH THE
BUSINESS LEADERS AND NEXT
STEPS ON ECONOMIC POLICY.
WE’VE GONE THROUGH THE LIQUIDITY
PHASE NOW WE’RE IN THE REOPENING
PHASE.
I THINK THE NEXT PHASE HAS TO GO
BACK TO OLD FASHION TRUMPONOMICS
, CUTTING TAXES, DE
REGULATING, THINGS THAT GREW
THE ECONOMY RAPIDLY IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS PLUS AND THINGS THAT
CAN GROW THE ECONOMY RAPIDLY IN
THE SECOND HALF AND ON TO NEXT
YEAR, AND THE PRESIDENT REBUILT
THE ECONOMY AND HE CAN DO IT A
SECOND TIME.
WE’LL HAVE THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION WITH THE CEOS AND
THE OTHERS.
>> EMILY: YOU MENTIONED NEXT
STEPS THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE U.S.
TREASURY SET ASIDE
$10 BILLION IN PAYROLL
PROTECTION PROGRAM FUNDING SET
ASIDE FOR COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
AND WHAT DO AMERICANS NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> WELL I THINK ON THAT POINT,
IT’S A QUESTION OF TRYING TO
PICK UP THE LOWER RUNGS OF THE
LADDER IF YOU WILL, THE
BOTTOM QUINN I’LL HIT THE
MOST, THE SMALLEST
BUSINESSES HIT THE MOST.
COMMUNITY BANKS BY THE WAY HAVE
STEPPED UP AND DONE PRETTY WELL.
WE’VE ISSUED I DON’T KNOW CLOSE
TO $600 BILLION WORTH OF LOANS
FOR ALL THIS I THINK THE PROGRAM
CONSTRUCTED BISECT MNUCHIN HAS
DONE VERY VERY WELL SO THIS JUST
ADDS TO THAT.
THERE MAY BE TECHNICAL CHANGES
AND CONGRESSIONAL LEGISLATION TO
EXTEND THE LIFE OF THE LOAN,
MAYBE AS MANY AS 24 WEEKS, WE’LL
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT BUT IT’S A
HOPEFUL SIGN.
THE KEY POINT HERE, WE’VE GOT TO
REWARD INDIVIDUALS FOR COMING
BACK TO WORK.
THAT’S POINT NUMBER ONE, THERE
WILL BE SOME KIND OF RE
EMPLOYMENT BONUS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THE
$600, THAT’S A DISINCENTIVE TO
WORK, AND THAT DOESN’T WORK, BUT
WE’LL HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL ON FOR
PAYROLL TAX CUTS, FOR
WORKING PEOPLE AND THAT’LL
GIVE THEM AN INCREASE IN MAKE
HOME PAY, AND WE’RE LOOKING
AT BUSINESS EXPENSES CAPITAL
GAINS AND WE WANT TO BRING
PEOPLE HOME FROM CHINA, SUPPLY
CHAINS WE ALL LEARNED THE HARD
WAYS AND THAT IS NOT RELIABLE
AND WE WANT TO HELP THEM WITH